a word warning you are about to embark  on a perilous journey  what I really want to know dad is why  are you wearing sunglasses everywhere  except where you need them most a bling  a name known also to disappear  I think I've done something interesting  this time I think you're going to find  this much more interesting  you alter destiny my darling wasn't it  fun child oh I so hope you enjoyed it  but this was only a taste a Miss Thomas  Evan and I designed this automaton to  test your internet and strength of  purpose I had some private research have  resulted in a momentous discovery  you mean to disobey my orders no sir  it's just that we're bearing directly to  a squall sir  is the same what does it do showing you  what it means to master destiny